good morning John songwriting is amazing
getting meaning into an aesthetically
pleasing structure is a really
interesting challenge and one that
creates a lot of beauty in the world but
this video is not about those times it
is about the worst moments in top-40
songwriting I get that this is extremely
subjective but what I'm thinking about
when I'm talking about bad songwriting
is when like aesthetics is deeply
sacrificed for meaning or meaning is
sacrificed for aesthetic the most clear
example of that second thing being LFO
summer girls right this song has a
preamble let us listen to it you're
saying this song is gonna be about the
summer we met okay excellent you are
describing the summer in question and
these huge makes pieces well it just
happened we are suddenly no longer
talking about this summer we are not
talking about a man's currently somewhat
racist stomach not upset that sick and
Hits is kind of a forced rhyme that's
fine but if you're gonna make a stretch
make a stretch for a reason especially
in the first line of the song an example
of a bad line being less intrusive
because emphasis isn't placed on it is
the meteor men beg to differ judging by
the hole in the satellite picture yes
this is a forced rhyme that doesn't seem
to understand climate science at all
that is inside of a verse that
essentially could be summed up by saying
it's cold no wait it's hot it's not
great but it's not emphasized so you
don't really notice it doesn't change
the feeling of the song as opposed to
Eminem undoubtedly has a mastery of
language and rhyme and storytelling and
meter and I do not understand how his
brain works but I also do not understand
how you do this okay
now you want to leave out the window
guess that's why they call it window
pane it just landed existed in the
middle of the verse it would have been a
throwaway little fun pun but because it
ends and there's this huge space it like
places so much emphasis on this terrible
pun which would be okay if the song were
not a deeply troubling exploration of
domestic violence it's not the worst
though we're still gonna get there
though it does hurt a little extra
because it's Eminem and I do not like
the way it hurts what about then when a
song sacrifices aesthetics for meaning
listen events wait do it again the worst
thing is that we've wrapped around to
another line which is okay if there's a
reason but there's no reason just leave
the word book out I get that it's a page
in a bow and up page it your history
book but the worst line we have arrived
is not one that sacrifices aesthetics
for a meaning or meaning for aesthetics
it's one that just does not even doesn't
even try to do either
[Music]
smoking funny things I will allow but
trying different things why why that
means nothing did you try a Boca burger
for the first time kid Rockne it's not
like other things don't rhyme with
things where we listening to the songs
that Skynyrd sings were you feeling like
Kings did Red Bull give you wings was it
something about the joy that summer
brings trying different things double
rhyming is an aesthetic sacrifice and in
this case it happens for no reason it's
the worst thing I've ever heard done I'm
a little warm to go outside I'll see you
on Tuesday
where the skies are so blue Sweet Home
Alabama love the skies are so blue like
it's the equivalent of that you want to
buy a book by this guy it's available
July 7th for pre-order now including a
book shop tour where the price is the
same as it is on Amazon but you get to
support local book shops I'm fine